dans tous ces enjeux climatiques et puis
encore une fois c'est même assez
ridicule s'ils voulaient d'isoler climat
du reste le climat je le rappelle c'est
simplement deux paramètres c'est
notamment enfin essentiellement la
chaleur et l'humidité c'est les deux
paramètres qui font que la vie n'est
viable sur terre donc quand vous touchez
au climat vous touchez à la viabilité de
la planète il suffit simplement de
rappeler ça sinon on n'était pas du tout
dans les choses sérieuses alors oui il
peut y avoir un problème il peut y avoir
un problème de justice sociale d'accès
l'énergie je vous rappelle qu'en france
et là vous avez totalement raison
il y à au moins 6 millions précaires
énergétiques c'est à dire de gens qui
dépensent au moins 10% de leurs revenus
pour se chauffer pour produire l'eau
chaude et jeunes intégrés même pas là si
vous les dépenses qui leur sont
nécessaires pour se rendre au travail
avec une voiture donc de deux façons
carbonée donc là on a vraiment un
problème effectivement il faut bien
pouvoir concilier les deux c'est à dire
à la fois la réduction de nos émissions
et puis effectivement le faire de telle
sorte que ce soit acceptable pour pour
les ménages surtout les les ménages qui
ont ciblé les plus faibles revenus je
rappelle qu'à l'échelle mondiale c'est
les 10% les plus riches de la possible
de la population mondiale qui aimait
grosso modo c'est un peu arrondie qui
est maître 50 % des gaz à effet de serre
mondiaux et puis c'est les 50 % les plus
pauvres qui n'en maîtres queux disent
donc effectivement il faut bien résonner
dans le cadre d'une écologie sociale si
elle de façon c'est très traditionnelle
des inégalités entre les gens ont
toujours eu pour fondement des
inégalités en matière d'accès aux
ressources naturelles
donc effectivement inégalités sociales
et inégalités écologiques de ce côté là
se recouvrent bon et ça c'est vraiment
un défi important c'est évidemment un
2-2 de décarbonés notre énergie sans
augmenter les inégalités c'est un vrai
défi ce n'est pas une chose simple
[Musique]